las restricciones vuelven a beijing y
shanghai las principales ciudades chinas
apenas una semana después de haber
cantado victoria en shanghai que levantó
la cuarentena el pasado 1 de junio
después de más de dos meses a partir de
este sábado será cerrado el distrito de
ming ham para que sus casi tres millones
de habitantes sean testados sólo volverá
a abrir después de haber analizado todos
los resultados y en beijing por su parte
el brote parecía controlado ya media
semana se informaba de un solo caso la
cifra más baja en el último mes ocurre
que no es un caso cualquiera se trata de
un hombre de la periferia que pasó una
noche muy intensa en media docena de
bares y restaurantes del barrio céntrico
de sanlitun como consecuencia los
lugares de ocio de buena parte de la
ciudad han vuelto a cerrar después de
apenas cuatro días abiertos el último
caso revela una vez más la dificultad de
embridar una variante tan contagiosa
como micro en ciudades tan densamente
pobladas como beijing shanghai no hay
sin embargo ningún signo de cambio en la
persistencia está la victoria lo dijo
ayer el presidente chino xi jinping que
pidió a los funcionarios
no dilapiden los logros conseguidos
durante estos dos años